[Musik]
möchtest du ein plätzchen habe ich heute
morgen frisch gebacken vielen dank
also ich will auch einst beliebte gesagt
hast die sind aber nicht von mir
wieso nicht weil die so wahnsinnig
lecker sind ja lecker gut das war der
letzte lisa möchtest du auch ein
plätzchen
danke was machst du da ich muss morgen
das thema recycling und umweltschutz im
unterricht behandeln aber ich weiß noch
nicht wie und wieso muss das problem ja
das thema ist total wichtig aber wenn
der unterricht nicht spannend ist dann
ist es total langweilig langweilig also
dass man auch wenn wir unseren planeten
weiterhin so ausbeuten
dann brauchen wir 2030 mindestens zwei
herren und du kannst deinen schülern
auch sagen dass jeden tag 130 tierarten
aussterben
nun also insekten fehlen auch dazu
statistisches thema das wohl
langweiliger wird es doch das ist viel
zu abstrakt meine schüler sollen ja
selber aktiv werden
sie soll ein umweltbewusstsein
entwickeln und sich über ihr
konsumverhalten klar werden
na ja es reicht eigentlich schon wenn du
mal kein plastik aus das soll ja sowas
von umweltschädlich das ist sogar auch
das ist super das ist ultra langweilig
also wenn sie mal eine woche auf plastik
verzichten würden dann würden sie ihr
merken was alles aus plastik ist hier
sitzt ein mensch mit zwei gehirn ganz
klar
was ist was ist gehirn
[Musik]